we get
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
the future is now just in my last video
we talked about how Stanford researchers
are making people speak again move limbs
again and even walk again after
injecting adult stem cells directly into
the brain in this video we'll be talking
about going to Mars
from doom to the Martian and Total
Recall it's been the stuff of science
fiction for the longest time but now
going to the Red Planet
is getting some serious thought by Elon
Musk so what exactly is going on
Elon Musk just announced his plans to
begin colonizing Mars he proposes that
he could have humans on Mars by 2024 and
used the same tech to get people to
travel anywhere around the world in
under one hour this is all going to be
done using a spacecraft codenamed the
bfr in a presentation at the
International Astronautical Congress in
Adelaide Australia musk outlined his
plan it's not the first time that has
talked about Mars his first public
interest in the Red Planet was expressed
back in 2001 and last year he claimed
that a million people could be on Mars
by the 2060 s this latest announcement
was more of a fine-tuning of that plan
so here's the rundown the bfr will stand
100 metres tall with 31 engines to lift
a payload of more than 4,000 tons into
space each of these engines will have
multiple redundancies built in in an
attempt to bring with the probability of
failure towards zero
the be a fire is slightly larger than a
Saturn V rocket which propelled
astronauts to the moon during the Apollo
missions to give you an idea it can
carry a cargo payload with a living
space that's eight stories tall and
holds more volume than an Airbus a380s
passenger cabin it also has a fin so
that it could be more easily
controllable in any atmosphere that it
comes across the payload section or the
part that's the interplanetary ship will
be 48 meters long and feature 40 cabins
each capable of carrying three people
despite this must claims that the
overall cost will be much cheaper than
other launch vehicles currently
available because it can safely return
to Earth and be reused he gave the
example of throwing away a two million
dollar Cessna light aircraft after every
one-way trip instead of investing in a
large passenger jet and footing the bill
for a half-million dollar return trip
the point being that although the
initial capital is higher in the long
run the jet will turn out to be much
cheaper in one case you have to build an
intact aircraft in the case just have to
refuel something so it's it's really
crazy that we will be stiff
stated Rockets and then crashed them
every time we fly this isn't Matt must
believes that he could send to be fr
cargo ships to Mars by 2022 with the
first two crewed crafts touching down
just two years later in the presentation
he went on to talk about how the bfr
could be used in other ways for example
the same technology can fly people
anywhere in the world in less than one
hour potentially revolutionising global
transportation with passengers paying
essentially the same as they do now for
a commercial airline ticket another use
for the BF r was to help build an
outpost on the moon
it's 2017 I mean we should have a lunar
base by now what the hell's going on
another brief suggestion with space
services this includes launching many
satellites at once or just one large
satellite with a surface area ten times
that of the Hubble Space Telescope
without a need for a complex unfolding
procedure once released this is possible
due to the large cargo area taking the
idea further old satellites and space
debris could be collected at much lower
costs construction of the BFI is set to
start in 2018 and the machinery for
building the engines has already been
ordered and is on its way
the end goal is to have as many as a
thousand ships in a holding pattern in
orbit around Earth then every 26 months
or so when Earth and Mars are aligned
the ships would unravel their solar
panels and leave for Mars the journey
would last three to six months and human
cargo and suppliers will be dropped off
every trip
so a lot of people are doubtful as if
this timeline is realistic or even
possible Ellen's company SpaceX has been
late on their promise for the Falcon
Heavy rocket by at least five years but
still some experts are hopeful Bobby
Braun NASA's former chief technologist
States quote while the timeline and
capabilities are certainly ambitious I'm
bullish on the US industry's ability to
carry out challenging and far-reaching
goals it's great to see the private
sector lead in this way and I hope we
see more of it unquote
it's not just building the rocket though
landing humans on Mars will be one of
the biggest technical undertakings of
all time
that being said the company has beaten
the odds before the main example being
reusable rocket boosters as for paying
for the project Musk's plan is as
follows SpaceX will build a stockpile of
the older Falcon 9 and Dragon capsules
and sell as many rights to space as
possible for cargo missions the revenue
from launching satellites and servicing
the space station will go towards the
bfr which the company will now focus its
attention on as it stands right now by
human standards Mars will kill you it
has unbreathable air and most of its
water is within subsurface ice deposits
there's certainly a lot of work ahead to
make this a reality but it seems like it
just could be possible a 2016 paper by
NASA detailed exactly how to enable a
Mars colony from their data received by
the Mars rovers according to NASA quote
the currently known resources on Mars
are massive including extensive
quantities of water and carbon dioxide
therefore carbon hydrogen and oxygen for
life support fuels and plastics and much
else recent technologies combined with
the vast natural resources should enable
serious pre and post human arrival end
quote
this all seems like a very long shot but
not so long ago air travel was thought
not to be possible so I'm interested to
know what you guys think do you think
this is going to be possible or do you
think unforeseen challenges will
the project for me personally I think
the bf is a pretty good idea a
standardized rocket to carry out many
space services and I think at least that
part of the plan will go ahead
so let's close out this video with some
images of the alien planet in HD glory
brought to us by NASA and the Mars
rovers this has been to go go heal been
watching cold fusion if you just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe thanks for watching and
let's see what the future holds
cold fusion it can you thinking
[Music]